meine community es gibt menschen die mit
ihrem bauch schlafen können es gibt
menschen die wunderbar zeitlosen
kürzester zeit ableiten können genau
diese menschen brauchen wir in
deutschland auch gefällt kommt zu einem
neuen video special gebeten mir eure
talente bestehen der marke heute
karriere in folge von das supertalent
mit pages zugeschickt ich schaue mir
gleich nach eindruck das gehöre einfach
den ihren einwendungen zu beginnender
verkleinerte kommt von adriana 3 1 5
[Musik]
hektar wunderbar talent wie eine gute
beispiele führt das ist doch noch
hoffnung in die jugend von deutschland
gibt eine weinflasche einheitlichen rate
was damit passiert kann heutzutage
wirklich nicht jeder werde ich beim
zweiten versuch hat diese verbrechen
rausschmeißen geschaffen würdigte wenig
verändert und stern vorliegt
[Musik]
danke auch an dich denke ich mir eine
zuversicht in die zukunft für das ist
noch sehr viele menschen die die
software einfach ihre reichweite und
sofort jetzt gerade nutzen um den leuten
was mit zu geben und zwar das mit dem
ball gefällt eine lösung von niemand
geringerem als wechsel kein tor
ihr kennt mich darauf die band in diesem
sinne supertalente auch hier an der
stelle liegt einfach im bett
die kamera an belegt sich den monaten
laut der für mich heraus kommt wenn wir
hier typisch denn tatsächlich unfall
reden kann ich kurz die caprica
plakative kassel einfach einmal
überprüfen und damit auf dem regal
unterlagen an nächster stelle haben wir
die heutige sendung
nächster punkt war die woche war wieder
dass der aus liebe liegt da der
mächtigsten aber das ist krieg oder die
finger gucken dann klappt andere städte
haben wir 23
[Musik]
sie haben ihre kaffeetasse wäre für
kataloge hauen alle islamische die sonne
persönlich sondern sehr bewährt
[Musik]
henning family schwierig aus bin ich
wirklich richtig spaß machen würde ich
will kein verbot ausdrucken ob das so
gemacht auf die funktionierenden
beispiel ich habe mit dem militär wird
über internet konfrontiert werden
natürlich mit dem connect eine
einsendung von elli rasen bereut und
[Musik]
schläft
das auto macht das hat mir die
kommentare besser gemacht hat kann man
sagen leute nicht nur die welt sondern
auch meine community es gibt menschen
die mit ihrem bauch schraubenkönig
menschen die wunderbar kite nur in
kürzester zeit abbrechen können und
genau diese menschen brauchen wir in
deutschland unter all diesen
zwischenfall wird eine paarung b wieder
hat verlost das gute will darauf dieses
apfel banane mit bip oder ok ohne ich
will keine scheine zucker in meiner
babynahrung hier oben bekommt ihr
persönliches video und glamour therapie
und hier oben die neueste folge macht
ist mein format mit mega projekt wieder
dazu schon weiter vielleicht da und ich
mal kommen